un escargot en nougatine 500 grammes de
douceur
voilà ce qui a bluffé le jury passe ma
pièce en nougatine qui présente un
escargot que c'est cette pièce qui m'a
fait gagner le concours 40 heures de
travail pour décrocher le graal de tout
apprenti c'est toi le meilleur apprenti
de france
oui mais moi ça fait bizarre très
bizarre
par exemple à l'école depuis que je suis
arrivé c'est tes meilleurs apprentis de
france de voile à l'école par et j'avais
des copains il criait une pièce qu'il a
imaginé et confectionné chez le
pâtissier cédric du chez son maître
d'apprentissage
depuis trois ans un pick-up n'hésite pas
à chauffer un tout petit peu l'endroit
du chocolat concrets pour bien faire
pour bien que ton chocolat il adhère le
premier apporte savoir faire et
expérience
le second fraîcheur et idées depuis
qu'il est meilleur apprenti de france je
commence à lui demander les petits
conseils des conseils de jeunesse
puisque de toute façon voilà par rapport
aux couleurs par rapport aux formes
donc nous on a un regard déjà un petit
peu plus anciens alors que dans ces des
personnes des personnes des ados quoi un
ado de 17 ans qui passent une semaine
par mois chez son patron et les trois
autres à l'école ici au centre de
formation de mercurey ou un tel titre
n'avait pas été décroché depuis 22 ans
c'est une récompense
pour le cfa bien sûr cette fois jean
lameloise c'est une récompense aussi
pour notre nos formateurs nous vous même
et
c'est sympa sympa d'avoir des jeunes
avec cette envie de continuer dans le
métier et avec pour celui là un rêve
ouvrir un jour sa boutique
c'est le rêve ultime la boutique c'est
ça
c'est ça concrétise les choses c'est moi
c'est ma passion donc vraiment la
boutique jusqu'au bout il a il a un don
il a du talent et avec cette motivation
et
et cette alchimie il va faire qu'il ira
très loin sur mais pour l'instant c'est
encore ici qu'ils inspirent ses
camarades des yeux pleins d'étoilés